With the arrival of Android Support Library version 26
We are focusing on a few key elements
We got a few new features about text and animation.
Balanced with the Android framework and multiple platforms
Support for (such as Wear and TV)
Also by moving the main SDK to 14
Abandoning 1400 methods and other means to reduce the size of the code base
Let's take a look at the new changes in text and fonts.
In the Support Library 26 we simplified
The process of manipulating custom fonts
Now you can use them just like any other resource.
Put it directly into a brand new font resource folder
We also now support downloadable fonts
This means you don't need to bind font files in the APK
The system will come from the font provider (Provider, as by Google Play Services
Provided by Google Fonts)
Find the right file for you
We need to talk about the expression before we mention the text.
You may have seen this sad square wrong character
This means that this app can't display emoticons
Adding a Unicode standard means
The operating system does not always have the latest fonts to display newer logos
Your app after the emoticon adapter appears
Easily compatible with emoticon support on the device
As long as the device APL level is not less than 19
Now you have three widgets
EmojiEditText EmojiTextView EmojiButton
Also supports widgets for the app
And the Helper class lets you use your own custom widgets
Emoticon adaptation can be configured as a binding or downloadable font
See the attached documentation for how to use it.
Suppose you want the text size of your text area
Can automatically expand or shrink to fill the layout
After the Support Library version 26 arrives
All you need to do is set the AutoView property of the TextView.
You can control the spacing size to use
Maximum and minimum text size definition step size
You can also provide a range of discrete sizes for use.
Our next topic is animation
Now you can implement animations driven by real physics
That is based on speed rather than time
This helps create smooth, natural animations
The effect will change as the target changes.
It also simplifies the process of switching between gestures and animations
We have two main entity-based animations
Spring and throw
If you have a view you can drag around the screen
But when you loose it
You want it to return to its original position
Using a spring-style animation will make the view look
Like being brought back by an invisible but familiar force
You can customize the stiffness damping coefficient of the elastic
And the final location
If you want to animate the properties of an object
And want this animation to end
Please use throwing animation
You can customize a variety of parameters such as initial speed
Friction and minimum and maximum animation values
If you work with vector graphics
Then you will be happy to see
Some features in your SDK
Also part of the support library
Vector drawing compatibility has a brand new attribute fill type
It determines which part of the image is inside the shape
This is similar to SPG's fill rule properties
Vector drawing compatibility is now available
Implement deformation and define path-based interpolators
Creating rich animations that can be traced back to API 14
Are you developing for Android Wear and Android TV?
We have good news for you.
The Wear online library is now a complete support library
Contains some classes that you may already be using
Such as box insertion layout slide to cancel the frame layout
Wearable recycler view
And some new components designed for action and navigation drawers
Leanback's API has made several changes
Includes new video playback controls with point-in-time positioning support
See the Leanback documentation to learn more
Support library for this version
We have other changes worth mentioning.
Percentage support module is deprecated
So you should use ConstraintLayout to handle the scale problem
We also have a new PreferenceDataStore API
Allows you to implement the storage you want
We also made behavior changes for the FragmentManager.
executePendingtransaction commitNow
And similar transaction calls
Will not be available when the FragmentManager status changes
Font emoticons automatically resize the TextView
Animation effect based on real physical laws
Vector graphics multi-device platform support, etc.
The new support library contains a lot of APIs
You can use them to build the best experience for your users.
For more information, please see the documentation page.
And Google I/O conversations
Contents about What's New in Support Library